The Hollywood Reporter's says the  chairwoman of miss Americas Board of  Directors former Fox News anchor  gretchen carlson denies she silenced and  bullied the current Miss America in a  letter sent Friday to former Miss  America's Carla Cara Munn said our chair  and CEO has had systematically silenced  me reduced me marginalized me and  essentially erased me Carlson responded  by tweeting she was surprised and  saddened about MUNs accusations she said  she had never bullied or silenced munde  Carlson also tweeted that Mons  allegations quote dilute the experience  for the next woman selected to wear the  crown